For most of human civilization,
we believed that life could only exist
on the surface of our planet.
What else?
Where we wrong about?
This world has more secrets
than we could possibly imagine.
what is that?
It’s not Kong.
Kong can't stop this on his own.
He won't be alone
Is that a mini Kong?
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
There's a brand new Godzilla X Kong Trailer
Godzilla and Kong teaming up against this new
orangutan Titan, which they're calling the Skar King.
Like the new main villain, Titan, in the trailer.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs here.
And we have Son of Kong.
Is that a mini Kong?
Like he literally calls it a mini Kong
I can't wait to see all the Kong Infinity
gantlet memes when this comes out like a sea
wearing an infinity gantlet.
Did they give him an infinity gantlet?
Perfectly balanced as all things you should be.
between this coming out next year,
Godzilla minus one being such
a banger of a good Godzilla movie
In the Monarch TV show.
Right now, Monsterverse fans are eating good
like it is a good time to be a fan of all this stuff.
Jews, starting at the beginning
of the trailer footage, working your way through, shot
by shot, talked about Easter eggs, wtf moments,
Godzilla x Kong the new Empire is basically
a reference to the hollow earth that is the new empire.
They say that the movie is going to challenge
your assumptions about the origins of the world.
Basically,
the actual full synopsis of the movie says it's
going to delve further into the histories of the titans
like the origins of the titans
the mysteries behind Skull Island and beyond,
while uncovering the mythic battle
that helped forge these extraordinary beings
and tie them to humankind forever.
but in the trailer, Rebecca Hall's character,
who comes back from the first film,
most of the characters in the first film
come back with a few exceptions,
talks about all the stuff that they're discovering
in the Hollow Earth, the origins of these other titans,
completely changing their ideas
on the origins of life on the planet.
not sure where this coastline is.
This doesn't look like Skull Island.
Then we travel to the pyramids
where Rebecca Hall is talking about
challenging our assumptions
about that knowledge of life on the planet.
Basically,
She's basically talking about all these other titans
and everything
that was going on in the Hollow Earth like, no, no, no.
That's where everything started.
Then we see Kong bursting through in what seems like
Egypt with a giant new weapon attached to his hand.
We see him running with later in the trailer.
I think that's to give him more of a fighting chance
against this other new orangutan titans
of the other titans. He's going to be fighting.
Then we go down to the hollow Earth.
And just like we saw in the last movie,
the perspective, which is a little bit
so it looks like you're seeing it upside down,
but it kind of exists in an upside down.
Like it's basically like a cave with part of it
existing on the roof of the cave and part of it
existing underneath.
Just the way the gravity works down there.
there we see what looks like monarch following
Kong through the Hollow Earth.
He does not have the weapon attached to his hands.
This might be earlier in the movie before he gets that
there was a couple of the characters
tailing Kong who are back from the first movie.
With a few exceptions.
Rebecca Hall is back.
Like I said, Brian Tyree Henry's Bernie Hayes is back.
He used to work at Apex, remember?
So he is actually pretty smart.
there was just that whole conspiracy theory
runner of his in the background during that last movie
it as we see later in the trailer Caleb Hoddle is back
as Gia who's just a little bit older in this movie,
obviously did a little bit of grown up
but as you probably saw,
this other dude with them here is Dan Stevens.
He's playing Doctor Trapper I don't know much about
what's going on with this character,
only that
he's like the main dude in the movie in this one.
then we get one of our first big reveals in the trailer
like big WTF moments.
And it is son of Kong Only Brian Tyree Henry calls
it Mighty Kong.
love the way that Kong is also fooled by this shadow
here like, got to get ready.
Somebody's going to come attack me.
Wait a minute.
Is like this tiny little mini version of me
they're couple of moments later
in the trailer that I think
let us know exactly where son of Kong came from.
He's not his actual son.
it seems like he was born
to two of the other members of Kong's raise here
who are forced to serve the skar king.
They're just like living down here in the hollow Earth
with the red hands painted on their chests.
but I think the whole son of Kong in this equation
here, like where this little mini
Kong becomes more of a son of Kong type of character,
like the classic Toho movies.
is that maybe it befriends Kong and Kong kind of takes
it under its wing, kind of the same way that it took
Jia under his wing, basically the same idea
just with another member of its race it.
I think part of the idea here
about learning the origin of the Titans,
the history of the Titans is that Kong learns
what happened to his race
because he saw a bunch of bones
of their people around that throne room were
it seems like the Kong's used to rule a long time ago
before the skar king came along.
So early theory is that Kong learns
what happened to Minnie Kong here,
that he's threatened by the Skar king.
The other members of his race
are basically trapped by him, and he wants to rescue
that, wants to save them.
that's why he probably takes on the skar
king, notice to later in the trailer,
Rebecca Hall's character
says that he will not be alone
because he has Godzilla, obviously.
And Godzilla is busy evolving his powers, too.
I think part of the idea is that
Kong has been living in the Hollow Earth
since the events of the first movie in discovers
what's going on with the mini Kong, the other Kong's
that are trapped the skar king and gets involved
in that battle on his own but then needs help
from Godzilla to actually defeat the skar king.
And that's how Godzilla comes back into the movie.
Now, you know, we need to do in the next movie too.
We're doing Son of Kong in this movie.
Eventually that means that the project
to try and do Son of Godzilla at some point to Dan
Stevens
character sees the red Handprint from the Skar king.
It's basically the blood of other titans.
It's like a Titan hunter or a Titan killer.
Basically, can see it literally
wearing the bones of other titans.
it looks like they discover the aftermath
of like some battle from the skar king
Rebecca Hall's character kind of discovers
what's going on.
Then Kong discovers the bones of his other ancestors.
then we see all of the other members of Kong's race
here.
This seem like they're trapped in what is like the
throne room of the makeshift throne room of the skar
king I did a video on this like a long time ago
when they released the teaser trailer.
I think it still looks like a giant orangutan,
like a 400 foot tall orangutan.
not sure what's going on with all these titans?
Why they're chasing Kong.
It might have something to do with the skar King
if he truly is king of the Hollow Earth right now,
ruling over the whole earth, maybe all the other titans
are just doing whatever he wants them to do.
Maybe he just sits them after Kong, like,
go kill that Then it looks like there's
actually a race of human beings
living in the hollow earth.
Now, this seems like Gere's character.
Or maybe somebody who's connected to Gere.
because his energy looks so similar to the energy
that's evolving Godzilla's new powers.
I would normally say that this area
here, like this temple, looking place,
is something connected to Godzilla,
but I don't think they're looking at Godzilla here.
Then it looks at the skar king unleashes
some of the titans on the surface,
and that's where the real threat in the movie
comes from.
Like the skar
king is threatening to take over the entire planet.
whatever's going on here.
It seems like Gere is just ascending that pyramid
Then it seems like
for a little while,
Kong has to deal with that threat by himself.
until they say that he will not be alone and we see
what's happening with Godzilla and it looks like he's
somewhere in the Arctic evolving his body using that
same hollow earth energy like that same purple energy.
you see his body rippling with it.
And when he uses his atomic breath later
in the trailer, it's purple instead.
There's
probably some other twist to the power to his body,
just like some super version of his atomic breath
or super version of his normal abilities.
That power himself up.
there's a quick montage of the skar king on his throne
with the bones of all of the other titans around him.
then we actually see him full on.
Like if you get a much better
look at him, these are all the members of Kong's race
that are being held captive.
Notice they got the red handprints all over their body
just to mark them as servitude to the skar king
there's a much better shot of Godzilla
powering up his atomic breath with his new power And
we see one of our big team-up moments with Godzilla,
King Kong, running together inside the Hollow Earth.
Just a couple of brothers
just trying to take down another villain.
in, like I said in this scene, Kong has that power up
weapon attached to his and maybe he gets that later
in the movie after they discover that his normal weapon
either gets broken or isn't enough to fight the skar.
KING because of the song they use to say
Welcome to my world, that's obviously another reference
to the Hollow Earth itself, in the end
with that funny tag scene of Brian Tyree
Henry calling son of Kong Mini Kong
even though the trailer only says the movie's
coming out in 2024, it's actually supposed to come out
at the very beginning of March 2024.
I don't know why they didn't put March in here.
Maybe they plan on shifting the day just a little bit
or they want to be a little more ambiguous about it.
overall, this is just a teaser trailer,
so it doesn't give us too much of the actual story.
It seems interesting.
There are a couple of interesting additions
like Son of Kong, this new Skar King.
I don't know how much of Godzilla's
origin story or Godzilla's
ancestors will be seen during the movie,
but it sounds like there'll be focusing a lot on Kong's
ancestors in his race in
I will say, if you have not seen Godzilla minus one,
it is probably one of the best movies of the year,
if not one of the best Godzilla movies of all time.
It is actually really, really good.
but it is a totally different type of energy
than these more modern monsterverse movies.
So if you're looking for something more
in the vein of Classic Godzilla, it was made on
like a budget of $15 million, but it is fantastic.
It looks fantastic post
all your reactions to this trailer in the comments
and if you have seen Godzilla minus one, also post
your reaction to that movie in these comments.
Do I haven't done any videos
for the Monarch Monsterverse TV series,
but so far it's been pretty solid there.
Supposed to be at least eight episodes,
I believe There's a bunch of big stuff coming up
because it was Brazil Comic-Con this weekend.
There's a bunch of trailers. I'll try to do videos
for everything as fast as possible,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channels.
You don't miss any of that
Click Here for My House of
The Dragon Season 2 Trailer video
and click here for the Boys Season 4 Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!